a lot of conversation there we're that
sever in command there also City general
about the need for level playing fields
on regulation between the US and Europe
Basel and other international bodies
have been trying to move towards that
for some time is that under threat now
with Trump in the White House well it's
great to be here with you Anna thank you
for having me yes I think it is under
threat President Trump has made it very
clear that he is not a supporter of
multilateral arrangements and Basel is
one of those and he's in terms of trade
very attached to bilateral deals where
he can negotiate something he sees as
America first and I think therefore the
likelihood of a trump administration
engaging in the next round of Basel
talks is actually quite low the level
playing field that Caban refers to that
it's not a level playing field
anyway the Americans don't have as much
weight on their on their balance sheets
as the European peers what we've got for
you is Europe versus US banks if you
looked at that you might say oh I want
to close that gap and there's a value
proposition there is there really a
value proposition there do the European
banks have enough capital how do you
look at that landscape I think this is a
value trap - I think that European banks
did not after the financial crisis do
the massive recapitalization the US
banks did it was very piecemeal in
Europe they have under recognized under
non-performing loans so I think European
banks are not in as good a capital
position really as their published
numbers suggest and for that reason I
think they will continue to slow the
creation of credit in Europe which is a
problem for the European economy so I
see the weakness of the banking system
particularly in Italy in Germany the
French are probably in a better position
than the Italians and the Germans as one
of the issues the other issue is the one
you refer to about the asymmetry of
regulation with the Trump administration
pushing to repeal dodd-frank that has
been one of their priorities from the
start and with Europe if anything
tightening regulation I think you will
see a lot of a regulatory arbitrage over
the next year or two in fact the big win
of brexit maybe New York rather than any
European center with that regulatory
symmetry yeah well maybe I'll pick up
that that scene when we talk a little
bit more about the UK later find out
which is that transatlantic divide is
opening up where does the UK fall in
that but sticking with the US for a
moment the dodd-frank that the review of
the dodd-frank legislation how positive
in the short term do you think that is
for the US economy and what are your
medium to longer term thoughts on here
I'm not so sure that the economic
benefit is as big as some people suggest
I don't think it's really been true that
healthy US businesses are failed to get
loans it's certainly been true at the
margin that businesses who might just
about justify alone have been under
scrutiny and maybe a repeal of
dodd-frank will make it marginally
easier but I think that the economic
impact of a repeal of dodd-frank is not
all that large the big impact is on the
banks you know think about a bank like I
don't know goldman sachs or JP Morgan
before the crisis their aspiration was
20% roee since the crisis and since
dodd-frank they think 9 is quite good
well repeal of dodd-frank probably gets
them up in the teens again and that's
why that price to boot may stay above 1
for the US bank well it's a good thing
for the banks because they'll be able to
make more money it may be a bad thing
long term for the financial system if
they over leverage in order to get those
high ro ease that could be the seeds of
a crisis in the longer term